so has something happened behind the
scenes that allows you to come forward
like what is the reason for you coming
forward now rather than before and when
i say coming forward i mean at least
this is your first time on video there
was only i think two images of you prior
to this
so i'm in my mind i'm wondering is this
related to the nimitz and the disclosure
in general
not at all sir i just
the the book by ross coldheart um
again the chapter 23 in which he
basically say are these patents uh
merely a pathetic bluff to scare off
america's rivals
i would not have done
i would have i would have not performed
due diligence as an engineer and as a
as a person that serves
the american people
and the federal government i would have
not done my due diligence if i were to
just
let it
just go by the wayside and say oh this
is
baloney because it is not a lot of work
went into these ideas a lot of work went
into these pattern applications
and they're not meant to scare off
anyone they're meant to ask questions
and possibly
open new avenues towards
new ideas that's all
sal
thank you so much it's time for me to do
my due diligence and go through some of
that work on the super force because i i
still i'm unclear
and i need to
gain some clarity so perhaps i can send
you some emails and ask you what what
does this mean what does that mean for
our next conversation to be a bit more
illuminating when it comes to quantum
gravity and the super force relationship
to it
sure sir and please uh if you see me not
responding right away is because i can
basically just work on this stuff during
weekends you and i have discussed this
previously so okay
i don't want you to take it as an
upfront or he's not
because it's no i know it's happened to
me when when people have
you know i i write emails and nobody
answers for weeks and i i tell you it's
not that i do this because uh in any way
it's an affront to you it's
i i'm extremely busy in my work at this
point in time and leave it at that yeah
okay and also same with myself if you
don't get a response right away
sometimes you may not get a response for
about a week or two hey
dude it's dude to you okay
please don't don't forget uh hyperlink
to this because my wife was really
interested it said what what's going on
here yeah yeah so you know thank you
very much sir you're welcome i i cannot
help calling you sir because it's a term
of respect
and i call people my my boss at work sir
it's just a term of respect people i
respect i call sir
in in private conversations i'll call
you dude and brother and so forth but
it's different
i tell you you are my brother
you and i
have a link our souls have a link i like
you very much on a personal level just
leave it at that all right
thank you sal thank you so i'm by the
way man when i say man like hey man so
that's my term of endearment okay i love
that i mean
i mean respect by that no no i had some
awesome friends in new york city that oh
my goodness oh the language we used i
could never use that heirs
leave it at that yeah